They're cute, they're lovable and, judging by the 26 billion views...
...of over two million YouTube videos of them pouncing, bouncing, climbing,...
...cramming, stalking, clawing, chattering, and purring,...
...one thing is certain: cats are very entertaining.
These somewhat strange feline behaviors,...
...both amusing and baffling, leave many of us asking, "Why do cats do that?"
They developed through time as both...
...solitary predators that hunted and killed to eat...
...and stealthy prey that hid and escaped to survive.
So, cats today retain many of the same instincts...
...that allowed them to thrive in the wild for millions of years.
This explains some of their seemingly strange behaviors.
To them, our homes are their jungles.
But if this is the case, in our own cat's eyes, who are we?
Big, dumb, hairless cats competing with them for resources,...
...terribly stupid predators they're able to outsmart every day,...
...or maybe, they think we're the prey.